Alam allayikum. My name is Ya and my
question is that the idea
>> what's your profession?
>> Uh I'm a teacher.
>> Okay.
>> Uh the idea of equality doesn't mean
equity. So everyone is different. They
have different roles to make the um
functions. But does that also apply to
knowledge? like I'm an English
literature student back then but I find
no correlation between how can I
function in umah when I become an expert
in this field of study. Meanwhile, they
say knowledge leads us to Allah. And
then uh how is the best way for us to
extract our specialty, our cib so that
this um can function to its best when in
our individual level we perform as our
best. Thank you. The sisters as the
question that we human beings are equal
but equality doesn't mean equity. I
rather say equality doesn't mean
identicality.
Equity is not the right English word. I
know you're English teacher.
I said equality does not mean
identicality. Equity is a different
meaning. And different meaning. So I say
that equality does not meanality.
And she said that knowledge
you use the word knowledge is I think
beneficial you use the word beneficial
or somewhat similar. Yes, it is
beneficial. So how can you use the
knowledge
in the case of a religion? Correct.
That's your question.
>> Uh I mean yeah how can
>> we use knowledge for the betterment of
the religion? You're an English teacher.
>> Yeah. Is that really my is that really
my signature of this um I don't know
>> yes sister has a question I do agree
that knowledge in most cases is
beneficial but wrong knowledge is not
beneficial for example for example you
are an expert in stealing
okay that knowledge can be changed for
the betterment you know we have
conferences of expert hacking hacking
conferences. So that knowledge actually
is used for wrong things. We can change
it for the better. He's an expert
hacker. You know hacking hacker. So they
have conferences of hackers. And who
wins? They many countries buy them pay
them good salary for what? Not to hack
to prevent hacking. So he's an expert
thief in stealing but if an expert he'll
also be able to stop other people from
robbing. So they get these hackers, they
pay them good salary, you stop the haram
work, now work for us and prevent other
people from hanking. So you can many a
time change the knowledge which is
damaging the ummah, damaging humanity to
a benefit cause. So knowledge generally
is beneficial but many of times it can
be harmful. You can convert that harmful
knowledge to a good purpose.
You ask the question that you are an
English teacher.
How can you benefit the um you can do
dawa with the English people?
Correct. You have to dawa in all the
languages. So read the Quran, understand
the Quran. Don't know Arabic, read the
translation of the Quran. You speak give
you speak very good English. No doawa to
the English people. Those who know
English, convert it. If Allah gave you
some ability,
if you know my background, I'm not a
very good speaker. I was a stammerer
in my childhood when I was young in
school. If you ask me what is your name,
I say my name is Zazak. I was a stammer.
I could have dreamt of becoming the best
doctor in the world. I could not have
dreamt of speaking in front of 25
people. But I met Shik Ahmed and one day
when I went on the stage I realized on
the stage I don't stammer. When I come
down in the stage I start stammering.
Ajib weird miracles on the stage I don't
stammer. come down sit I start
stammering when I speak with Muslims I
start stammering when I speak with
non-Muslims stammering vanishes so
I am a very bad speaker but because I
loved Allah I met Shik Ahmed Da I
started dawa and I become a speaker
no one could have thought Dr. Because
Akai can speak in front of 25 people,
leave aside 10,000, 25,000, 100,000.
So when we love Allah and we strive in
his way, Allah opens up your pathways.
Allah says in surah kapur 29:69, you
strive in is when Allah will open up his
pathways. Allah subhanana wa ta'ala has
given every human being somehow the
other ability. It is upon you whether
you use it for a good cause or bad
cause.
Some people use it on the bad cause want
to steal, want to rob.
Someone give you intelligence, use it
for dava. Some people use it for wrong
things. If Allah has given you some hun,
some ability,
you have to use that ability in the way
of Allah subhana wa t'ala. Then you get
benefit in this world. And
if you use it, so see to it, you study
the Quran, study the Sharia. Where can
you use where can you use your ability
which becomes either fur or mustab.
So if you say you are well versed in
English language I would say you can be
a very good ayah among the ladies
okay keep on teaching English teaching
English is not haram
it's a language as Allah says he has
made different languages very good and I
mean I I told my son okay two languages
Arabic language of Quran and English
international language then local
language it's good international
language you can use the ability to
explain and if your English is good
maybe people will get impressed
Oh, very good English. So, but with
logic, with hikma, with ability and
inshallah, so you have to use the
ability Allah has given you so that you
get the benefit in this world and the
hope that answers the questions.
>> Thank you.